週刊金融日記
にせんにじゅうろくねん八月二十五日 第七百四十五号
なぜエーアイと半導体をめぐる天井なき果てしなき軍拡競争は決して避けられない運命なのか、米財務省の国債買い戻しでドル安円高・ビットコイン暴騰、東京に来たら鮮魚を扱う大衆店が粉ものや中国産冷凍食品のお店になっていた件、結婚して週刊金融日記を卒業しましたが八年ぶりに帰ってきました、他。
ウェブ版です。
こんにちは。
ふじさわかずきです。
じつは、自動車免許の更新など、いろいろ用事があって、東京に帰ってきました。
週末に戻ってきて、おお、思ったより涼しい！
と思ったら、夕方にはゲリラ豪雨が襲ってきたり、夜中にスマホの緊急地震警報で叩き起こされたり、久々に東京の大自然から洗礼を受けました。
東京・埼玉に「レベル4 大雨危険警報」。
関東にゲリラ雷雨が発生しています。
大雨で、汚水が東京湾に大量に流れてきていますが、この辺のインフラ整備は本当にがんばってもらいたいですよね。
『週刊金融日記 第六百十八号 東京のウォーターフロントを浄化すれば芝浦や港南が港区覇権争いで下剋上できる』
しかし、東京は、高級店以外の和食というか、大衆店の鮮魚などはかなりアレなんですが、フレンチとイタリアンは本当にコスパがいいですよね。
何度も言っていますが、東京で美味しいのはフレンチとイタリアンなんですよ！
丸の内のカジュアルと高級の中間ぐらいのフレンチで、居酒屋みたいに取り皿持ってきてもらって、みんなで頼んだメインを取り分けて、美味しいフランスワインをごくごく飲んで、最高です。
日曜日のブランチはアメリカンで、東京の洋食は素晴らしいですね！
サラダ中心でヘルシーなブランチです。
次に行ったイタリアンも良かったです。
メルマガで紹介しますわ。
エックスサブスク（月三ドル）は、アップルやグーグルにピンハネされるスマホのエックスアプリからではなく、宇宙開発を応援するためにも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのエックスのウェブをブラウザで開いていただいて、そこから直接ポチっていただけると助かります。
こんしゅうは大注目のエヌビディアの決算です！
エーアイ革命の覇者 エヌビディア エフワイにせんにじゅうななねん キューツー決算。
こんしゅうも読者から興味深い投稿がいくつもあります。
見どころは以下のとおりです。
キオクシアよりもエイチビーエムトップのエスケーハイニクスのほうがよいのではないか。
オラクルに関してはどうお考えですか。
さいきんはエーアイと半導体の話が多いですが、中国株や中国の政治経済の話をもっと聞きたいです。
結婚して週刊金融日記を卒業して早八年、セックスレスに耐えきれず帰って参りました。
それではこんしゅうもよろしくお願いします。
**１．なぜエーアイと半導体をめぐる天井なき果てしなき軍拡競争は決して避けられない運命なのか**
こんしゅうは、エーアイと先端半導体についてのだいじな話をしたいと思います。
メモリ半導体なんか特にそうですが、かなり地味な業界でした。
好況のときに増産のためのせつびとうしをして、それで製品が世に出るのが三年後とかなんで、構造的に不安定で、いわゆるシリコンサイクルを繰り返してきました。
それが、二〇二二年十一月三十日に、ChatGPTが彗星の如く現れ、急に計算資源の獲得競争になりました。
さいしょは、学習用ジーピーユーの需要が異常に増えました。
多くのユーザーがエーアイを使うようになり、推論（inference）の計算が増えると、メモリ需要も爆増したわけです。
そして、半導体は、一気に、世界の中心的な産業へと変貌を遂げました。
しかし、そろそろ、エーアイもさまざまな用途で十分な性能を獲得してきたのだから、エーアイ開発競争も落ち着き、それゆえに、こうしたジーピーユー、シーピーユー、メモリなどの半導体への需要もなくなっていくのではないか、という意見もあります。
本当にそうなのか、こんしゅうは考えてみたいと思います。
まずは読者の方の投稿です。
+++++++++++++++++++++++++++
エーアイ半導体の供給過多論と「計算の圧縮」の可能性についてです。
いつも示唆に富むメルマガありがとうございます。
「半導体需要がこんだけあるのにツルハシ銘柄は歴史的なミスプライスなのか？
」という文脈において、計算の「圧縮」みたいな方向でブレークスルーが起きて供給過多になるリスクはどのくらいあるのでしょうか？
発想のもとになった連想、帯域幅と圧縮の歴史についてです。
九十年代前半、子どもの頃に「テレビも電話もあるのに、なぜテレビ電話はできないのか」と父（当時、半導体商社に勤務）に尋ねたところ、「個人が動画をやり取りするには帯域幅がまるで足りないので、技術的に無理だ」という答えが返ってきました。
しかし実際には、その後十五年〜二十年ほどでデータ側を「圧縮する」発想で技術が進歩し、誰もがビデオ通話をする時代になりました。
もちろん光ファイバーや無線通信の進化という物理の前進もありましたが、少なくとも私の理解では「とにかく太いケーブルを何本も引く」といった力任せの物量勝負が主戦場だったわけではない、という印象を持っています。
このあたりは素人考えですので、実態は不明です。
さらに言えば、通信速度の改善は、現在も地道に続いてはいるものの、かつてほど産業全体の主戦場ではなくなっているようにも見えます。
伺いたいことです。
計算行為の「圧縮」はどの程度起こり得るか。
モデルの軽量化や推論効率の改善技術が、ジェボンズのパラドックスを考慮してもなお、飛躍的に需要を効率化させて、いまの増産体制を空振りさせるような可能性はあるのでしょうか？
それともやはり、効率化はかえって利用機会を増やし、結果的に総需要を押し上げる方向に働くのでしょうか。
余談ですが、需要逓減には「人間側のフィジカル・知覚的な基準」も関係するのではないか、という考えがあります。
通信速度の話に戻すと、四ケー六十フレームパー・セコンド動画を快適に視聴できるようになったここ五、六年で、話題に上がることが少なくなったように、主観的には感じます。
フレームレートにせよ解像度にせよ、このへんが平均的な人間の知覚能力的に「これ以上追求しても大して違いがわからん」という分水嶺なのではないでしょうか。
つまり、分野が異なっても、人間の平均的な知覚水準に到達した時点で「もうこれで十分」という空気になって、その領域の開発競争そのものが沈静化していくような力学が、エーアイにも働く可能性はあるのか。
だとすると、もう、エフエーベル（Fable）なんかほぼ人間みたいな文章書けるし、大多数の人間はチャットボット的な利用に終始して、一部の優秀層以外「生産性を上げるためのエーアイの使い方」を思いつくことにそもそも苦慮しているという現状から鑑みるに、意外と早く世間から飽きられる可能性もあるのかな、とかリスクも考えています。
当然、仕事で本当に人間の役に立てるような、いわゆるエージーアイは、まだまだ先かもしれませんが、平均的な人間はばかなので、エフエーベル五とエージーアイの差を体感できない可能性があります。
上記、ご回答いただければ幸いです。
同じ質問を五・六ソルとエフエーベル五にぶつけてみたら、下記回答でした。
+++++++++++++++++++++++++++
まずは、こうしたことを議論する前に、絶対に知っておかないといけないことがあります。
それはスケーリング則です。
これゆえに、はいぱーすけーらーにしろ、エヌビディアにしろ、市場参加者の多くがピンと来てなかったころから、あんなに自信満々に莫大な資金を投入して、計算資源の獲得競争にフルスロットルで突っ込んでいったわけです。
現在、それはますます加速しています。
スケーリング則というのは、一言でいえば、「エーアイに投入する計算資源を増やせば増やすほど、エーアイの性能は予測可能なかたちで上がり続ける」という経験則です。
二〇二〇年に [EN]OpenAIのJared Kaplanらが発表した論文（Kaplan et al., "Scaling Laws for Neural Language Models", 2020）で定式化され、[/EN] これがその後のエーアイ開発競争のすべての出発点になりました。
ちなみに共著者には、のちにアンソロピックを創業するDario Amodeiの名前もあります。
彼らが発見したのは、次のような驚くほどシンプルな関係です。
エーアイの賢さは「損失（loss）」という数字で測ります。
これは、次に来る単語をどれだけ外すか、つまり誤差のことで、小さいほど賢い。
そして、この損失エルは、モデルの大きさ（パラメータ数エヌ）、データ量（ディー）、計算量（シー）のそれぞれに対して、
エル∝ 一/えっくす の あ乗（えっくすはエヌ、ディー、シーのどれか）
というべき乗則に従って下がっていくのです。
べき乗則というのは、両対数グラフにプロットすると、きれいな直線になる関係です。
Kaplanらの実験では、この直線が、計算量にして一千万倍以上のスケールにわたって、まったく崩れませんでした。
これがなぜ革命的だったのか。
それは、エーアイの性能向上が「予測可能」になったからです。
冒頭のシリコンサイクルのように、巨額の研究開発やせつびとうしというのはギャンブルです。
十億ドル注ぎ込んでも、成果が出るかは分かりません。
ところがエーアイは違ったわけです。
「あと百倍の計算資源を注げば、性能、つまり知能はここまで上がる」と、モノを作る前から分かってしまうわけです。
つまり、ジーピーユーへの投資が、ギャンブルではなく、リターンがほぼ確定した投資になったわけです。
はいぱーすけーらーやオープンエーアイ、アンソロピックの経営陣が、世間がまだ半信半疑だった頃から、あれほど自信満々に巨額のせつびとうしを続けられたのは、彼らがこの直線を社内の実験でなんども確認していたからです。
[EN]2022年には、Google DeepMindが重要な修正を加えます（Hoffmann et al., "Training Compute-Optimal Large Language Models", 2022）。
DeepMindが400個以上のモデルを訓練して調べ直したところ、実は「モデルの大きさとデータ量は、同じ比率で増やすのが最適」で、目安はパラメータ1個あたり約20トークン、ということが分かりました。
[/EN]
ジーピーティー・スリーを含む当時の巨大モデルは、実は図体ばかりデカくて勉強量が足りない「訓練不足」だったのです。
実際、七十億パラメータと比較的小柄なチンチラというモデルが、大量のデータで訓練されることで、二百八十億パラメータのモデルを打ち負かしました。
この発見以降、各社は「もっとデータを、もっと計算を」という方向に舵を切り、データ量の争奪戦も始まりました。
しかし、スケーリング則は、あくまで経験則です。
なぜべき乗則になるのか、理論的にはよく分かっていません。
だから「いつか崩れるのではないか」という議論が定期的に起こります。
実際、二〇二四年の終わり頃には、「事前学習のスケーリングは頭打ちになった」という報道が相次ぎ、Sam Altman解任騒動の後、二〇二四年にオープンエーアイを去った世界トップクラスのエーアイ研究者Ilya Sutskeverも「我々が知る形の事前学習は終わる。
インターネットは一つしかなく、データはエーアイの化石燃料だ」と講演で述べました。
しかし、ここからが面白いところで、スケーリング則は死んだのではなく、新たな形に生まれ変わったのです。
二〇二四年秋にオープンエーアイが出したオー・ワンというモデルは、答える前に「考える」モデルでした。
このモデルは、数学やプログラミングのように正解を機械的に検証できる問題を大量に解かせ、正解にたどり着いた思考の道筋だけを強化する、という大規模な強化学習で訓練されています。
そしてオープンエーアイは、この強化学習に注ぐ計算量を増やせば増やすほど、さらに、こうして訓練されたモデルに推論時に考えさせる時間、つまり推論時の計算量（test-time compute）を増やせば増やすほど、答えの質が対数グラフ上で直線的に上がり続けることを示しました。
事前学習に加えて、強化学習の計算量、そして推論時の計算量という、新しいスケーリングの軸が二本も見つかったわけです。
エヌビディアのジェンセン・ファンが最近しきりに「三つのスケーリング則が同時に働いている」と言っているのは、このことです。
冒頭の問いに戻りましょう。
エーアイ開発競争はそろそろ落ち着くのではないか。
スケーリング則が教えてくれるのは、その逆です。
計算を注げば賢くなる、という関係が一本でも生きている限り、ライバルより先に降りた者は、確実に負けます。
しかも推論時計算のスケーリングは、ユーザーがエーアイを使えば使うほど計算需要が増えるという性質を持っています。
学習は一回で終わりますが、推論は毎日、全世界で、永遠に続くのです。
メモリ需要が爆増しているのは、まさにこの構造によるものです。
もちろん、この計算資源の獲得競争の裏側で、アルゴリズムの効率化も猛烈な勢いで進んでいます。
象徴的なのが、二〇二四年末から二〇二五年一月にかけて世界を騒がせた中国のディープシークです。
彼らが二〇二四年十二月に公開したブイスリーというモデルは、六百七十億パラメータの巨大モデルなのですが、エムオーイー（Mixture of Experts、専門家混合）というアーキテクチャを採用していて、一つひとつの単語を処理するときに実際に動くのは、そのうちの三百七十億パラメータだけです。
脳全体を常にフル回転させるのではなく、質問に応じて必要な専門家チームだけを呼び出すイメージです。
さらに計算精度を八ビットに落とすエフピーエイト訓練などの工夫も重ね、対中輸出規制版の性能が制限されているジーピーユー（エイチ八百）わずか二千四十八基、約二ヶ月、費用にしてたった五百五十八万ドルで、ジーピーティーやClaude 3.5 Sonnetに匹敵するモデルを作ってしまいました。
米国のフロンティアモデルの訓練費用は数千万〜一億ドル級と推定されていましたから、文字通り桁が一つ違います。
そして翌二〇二五年一月二十日には、このブイスリーをベースにオープンエーアイのオー・ワンに匹敵する推論モデルアール・ワンを、重みまで無料で公開しました。
このアール・ワンの衝撃が市場に広がった一月二十七日、エヌビディア株は一日で十七パーセント暴落し、時価総額にして約六千億ドルという史上最大級の吹き飛び方をしました。
「効率化されたらジーピーユーはこんなに要らないじゃないか」というわけです。
ディープシークショックですね。
実際、Epoch エーアイの研究によれば、同じ性能を達成するのに必要な計算量は、アルゴリズムの進歩だけで約八ヶ月ごとに半減しており、[EN]（Ho et al., "Algorithmic Progress in Language Models", 2024）[/EN] これはムーアの法則よりずっと速いペースです。
しかし、ここで冷静に考えなければいけないのは、効率化はスケーリング則を破ったわけではまったくない、ということです。
むしろ話は逆です。
スケーリング則のグラフを思い描いてください。
横軸が計算量、縦軸が損失の、あの右肩下がりの直線です。
アルゴリズムの改善がやっているのは、この直線を少し下にずらすこと、つまり、同じ計算量でより良い性能が出るようにすることです。
しかし、直線の傾きそのもの、すなわち「計算を増やせば増やすほど賢くなる」という関係は、全く変わりません。
だから、ディープシークの効率的な手法は、ジーピーユーを不要にするどころか、そのままフロンティア勢の巨大クラスタに輸入されて、「では同じ手法で百倍の計算を注いだら何ができるか」という競争の新しいスタート地点になるだけなのです。
事実、ディープシーク自身も、安く作れたから開発を縮小するどころか、より多くのジーピーユーを求め続けています。
そしてマイクロソフトのサティア・ナデラ シーイーオーは、暴落の最中に「ジェボンズのパラドックス」という言葉を持ち出しました。
十九世紀の英国で、蒸気機関の燃費が良くなったら石炭の消費はむしろ増えた、という話です。
エーアイが安くなれば、エーアイの利用は爆発的に増え、計算需要の総量はかえって膨らむ。
実際、エヌビディア株はその後、暴落分を埋めてさらに高値を更新していきました。
たしかに、多くのテクノロジー製品には「これで十分」という天井があります。
エーアイが出てくる前のスマホ時代を思い出してください。
あの頃、半導体株はいつもシリコンサイクルにおびえていました。
ディスプレイの解像度が上がり、カメラの画素数が増え、同じようなスマホが毎年出てくるたびに、みんなあきらかに白けていきました。
四ケー動画が快適に見られるようになった頃から、通信速度の話題も減りました。
読者の方の指摘どおり、これらは人間の目や耳という、固定されたハードウェアの知覚限界に到達したら、そこで需要の伸びが止まるのです。
網膜の解像度を超えたピクセルに、より高い金を払おうというユーザーは多くはありません。
では、エーアイ、すなわち知能にも、同じような天井があるのでしょうか。
僕は、ないと考えています。
それは、生物学と文明史を見れば分かります。
先日、東京のスーパーマーケットに行ったのですが、そこには美味しそうなステーキ肉や鶏肉が、きれいにパックされて並んでいました。
しかし、考えてみてください。
なぜそこに並んでいるのが、人間の肉ではないのか。
牛は体重が人間の十倍もあり、力もずっと強い。
それでも柵の中で草を食べ、順番に食肉処理場へ送られていくのです。
製薬はいまエーアイの応用で最もホットな分野のひとつですが、生物学者たちは、まずマウスで実験をして、見込みのありそうな候補を、より人間に近い猿で試します。
では、なぜ猿は、人間を使って、猿に役立つ薬を研究していないのでしょうか。
いうまでもなく、人間が地球で最も知能の高い生き物であり、それゆえに食物連鎖の頂点どころか、他のすべての種の運命を決める立場に君臨しているからです。
ここでだいじなことは、人間と猿の知能の差など、宇宙的なスケールで見ればごくわずかだ、ということです。
ディーエヌエーは九十八パーセント以上同じです。
しかし、そのわずかな差が、実験する側とされる側、食べる側と食べられる側を分けたのです。
人間同士の文明史を見ても、まったく同じ構造があります。
北米大陸のネイティブアメリカンは、ヨーロッパから来た入植者にいいように弄ばれ、土地を奪われ、殺され、その上で、あたかも彼らのほうが野蛮な悪者であるかのようなプロパガンダ映画までバンバン作られて、書き換えられた歴史が世界に流布されました。
まったくもって酷い話です。
なぜこんなことが可能だったのか。
ヨーロッパ人のほうが科学技術が進んでおり、殺傷能力の高い武器を持ち、組織力があり、戦術に長けていたからです。
そして、勝った後は、メディアを支配する力を使って、物語まで自分たちの都合のいいように書き換えました。
同じことは、産業革命にいち早く成功した欧米列強と、出遅れたアジア・アフリカの間でも起きました。
技術力の差は、そのまま支配と被支配の関係に変換されたわけです。
もうお分かりでしょう。
ディスプレイの解像度は「人間の目」という固定された基準で測られる、絶対的な性能です。
だから天井がある。
しかし、知能は違います。
知能の価値は、常に「相手より賢いかどうか」という相対的な基準で測られるのです。
将棋のエーアイ同士の対局を人間が見ても、もはやどちらが良い手を指しているのか分かりませんが、盤上では必ずどちらかが勝ちます。
市場でも、戦場でも、外交でも同じです。
自分のエーアイが人間の知覚水準で「もう十分賢い」かどうかは、どうでもいいのです。
ライバルのエーアイより賢いかどうかが、すべてなのです。
そして、知能とは、資源の配分を決め、ルールを作り、歴史の物語を書く側に回るためのチケットですから、この競争にはそもそも「十分」という概念が存在しません。
あるのは「相手より上か下か」だけです。
だから、企業も国家も、この競争から降りるという選択肢を持てないのです。
降りた者がどうなるかは、スーパーの精肉コーナーと、ハリウッドの西部劇が教えてくれています。
我々と猿の運命を分けたのがわずかな知能の差だったように、エーアイの性能のわずかな差が、勝者と敗者を分ける。
そして、スケーリング則で解説したように、その知能は計算資源を注げば注ぐほど上がっていくことが保証されています。
[EN]●Kaplan, J., et al. (2020). Scaling Laws for Neural Language Models.
●Hoffmann, J., et al. (2022). Training Compute-Optimal Large Language Models.
●Ho, A., et al. (2024). Algorithmic Progress in Language Models.[/EN]
**２．こんしゅうのマーケット**
二〇二六年八月十四日から二〇二六年八月二十一日の週間パフォーマンスです。
[EN]TOPIX:      4067.29, -3.1% (1w), +18.7% (YTD)
S&P500: 7674.37, -1.4% (1w), +12.1% (YTD)
USD/JPY:     158.94, -0.3% (1w),  +1.6% (YTD)
EUR/JPY:     185.68, +0.7% (1w),  +1.1% (YTD)
Oil(WTI Fut): 87.06, +5.7% (1w), +51.6% (YTD)[/EN]
米財務省の国債買い戻しでドル安・円高、ビットコイン暴騰、エヌビディア決算に注目です！
金融日記 Weekly、二〇二六年八月十四日から二〇二六年八月二十一日についてです。
せんしゅう、八月十四日から二十一日のかぶしきしじょうは、エーアイ半導体の個別材料よりも、米国の長期金利と中東情勢に振り回された一週間となりました。
トピックスは週間で三・一パーセント、エスアンドピー五百は一・四パーセント下落し、ナスダックも二・一パーセント安となりました。
ホルムズ海峡を巡る緊張が続くなか、ダブリューティーアイ原油先物は五・七パーセント上昇して八十七ドル台となり、原油高と長期金利上昇がかぶしきしじょうの重石となりました。
エーアイ半導体株も [EN]NVIDIA（-4.6％）、Broadcom（-6.2％）、AMD（-8.0％）、ASML（-4.4％）[/EN] と軟調だったが、業績悪化というより高ピーイーアール株のバリュエーション調整という色彩が強いです。
いっぽう、医薬品株は逆行高となり、モデルナはマークと共同開発する個別化エムアールエヌエーがんワクチンがメラノーマの第三相試験で良好な結果を示し、株価が一時百七十七パーセント高と暴騰しました。
今回の成功そのものはエーアイ創薬ではありませんが、こんごエーアイが標的探索、分子設計、患者選別など製薬アール・アンド・ディーの生産性を飛躍的に高めれば、バイオ・製薬もエーアイ革命の大きな受益産業になっていくでしょう。
市場を大きく揺らしたのが、ベッセント米財務長官による突然の国債買い戻し拡大であります。
米三十年国債利回りが五・三十四パーセントと二〇〇七年いらいの高水準まで上昇した直後、財務省は十〜三十年の長期国債について、一回当たりの買い戻し上限を従来の二十億ドルから少なくとも四十億ドルへ倍増すると発表しました。
発表を受けて長期金利は急低下し、ドルは全面安となりました。
これはエフアールビーの量的緩和とは異なり、財務省が新たに通貨を発行するわけではありません。
しかし、市場が驚いたのは金額そのものではなく、「長期金利が上がりすぎれば政府が介入する」というシグナルであります。
先日の円買い協調介入に続き、今度は米国債市場にも直接手を突っ込んできたことで、トランプ政権は高金利とドル高をかなり嫌っている、との見方が強まりました。
そして、この「ドルの価値を薄める政策」への反応として派手に買われたのが金とビットコインだったのです。
ビットコインは週間で約二十パーセントも急騰しました。
国債買い戻しが暗号資産市場へドルを直接注入したわけではありませんが、「巨額財政赤字を抱える米政府は長期金利上昇に耐えられず、最終的にはドル安を選好するのではないか」という通貨価値希薄化のストーリーと、発行上限が二千百万枚に固定されたビットコインは非常に相性がいい。
ショートポジションの強制決済も加わり、上昇が増幅されました。
ドル円も百五十八円台まで円高となりました。
こんしゅう最大のイベントは、何といっても二十六日のエヌビディア決算であります。
前四半期の売上高は前年同期比八十五パーセント増の八百十六億ドル、データセンター部門は九十二パーセント増の七百五十二億ドルだったのです。
会社は今回キューツーについて売上高九百十億ドル・プラスマイナス二パーセント、ノン・ギーエーエーピー粗利益率七十五パーセントをガイダンスしており、この数字には中国向けデータセンタージーピーユー売上をまったく織り込んでいません。
市場予想は売上高約九百二十億ドル、イーピーエス二・〇九ドルで、調整後イーピーエスは前年同期比でほぼ倍増する見通しであります。
これほど巨大になった企業がなおこの速度で成長していること自体が驚異的であります。
決算で見るべきポイントは、数十億ドル程度の上振れそのものではありません。
ベラ・ルービンの量産立ち上げが予定通り進んでいるか、エイチビーエムなどメモリ価格の高騰を吸収しながら七十五パーセント前後の粗利益率を維持できるか、米政府が輸出を認可したエイチ二百の中国向け出荷がどこまで上振れ要因になるか、そして [EN]Apollo、BlackRock、Blackstone、Goldman Sachs、[/EN] ケーケーアールなどと組んだ五千億ドル超のエーアイインフラ金融プラットフォームが、顧客の資金制約をどこまで取り除くかに注目したいのです。
こうした金融面での関与を「循環取引」と批判する論調もありますが、高価でキャッシュフローを生む設備に金融を付けて市場を拡大すること自体は、自動車ローンや航空機リースと同じく特別な話ではありません。
マイクロソフト、アルファベット、アマゾン、メタがせつびとうしをさらに増やし、計算能力の供給不足を訴えている現状を見る限り、エヌビディアの需要が急停止する兆候はほとんど見当たりません。
筆者は引き続き、エーアイブームの王者エヌビディアに極めて強気であります。
エヌビディア決算以外では、二十六日に米四〜六月期ジーディーピー改定値、七月ピーシーイー、個人所得・個人消費など重要なマクロ指標が発表されます。
そして二十七〜二十九日にはジャクソンホール会議があり、ウォーシュエフアールビー議長が議長就任後初めて登壇します。
米財務省が長期金利上昇を抑えに動いた直後だけに、エフアールビーがインフレと金利をどう評価するかは極めて重要であります。
エヌビディアがエーアイ投資の加速を再確認し、ピーシーイーが落ち着き、ウォーシュ議長が追加利上げに慎重な姿勢を示せば、今回の株価調整は再び絶好の押し目だったということになりそうだ。
モデルナ株百七十七パーセント高、空売り勢八千七百億円含み損。
メラノーマ治験「勝利」。
米欧の長期金利が急低下、買い入れ奏功。
ドル全面安で円百五十八円台前半。
米財務省の国債買い入れ、マーケット想定外。
「政権の金利警戒強い」。
米国債買い入れ拡大でドル先安観。
「急場しのぎ」。
ツイストオペほうふつとの声。
米トランプ政権が国債の買い戻し額を拡大。
日米協調介入に続く市場介入。
日本の政策への介入も強めるか。
ビットコイン急騰、一時七・七パーセント高。
トランプ氏と業界幹部の会合控え。
メタプラネットシーイーオー、ビットコイン急騰の要因は「暗号資産ニュースではなく米財務省の流動性拡大」と指摘。
エヌビディアが二十六日決算、売上高「倍増」に死角あるか。
金融連携も焦点。
エヌビディア、エーアイ需要を自ら押し上げる成長戦略。
巨額投資に潜む死角。
エックスサブスク、三ユーエスディー・マンスで、主要企業の決算分析や、エーアイバブルの現在位置について筆者とエーアイの対談記事が読めます。
購読希望の方は、アップルにピンハネされるアイフォンアプリからではなく、スマホやピーシーのブラウザからエックスのサイトを開き、そこで直接サブスクリプションを登録して、ついでに、イーロン・マスク氏の宇宙開発も同時に応援してください。
**経済指標カレンダー**
八月二十四日（月）米七月シカゴ連銀全米活動指数。
八月二十五日（火）日七月百貨店売上高。
米六月ケース・シラー米住宅価格指数。
米七月新築住宅販売件数。
米八月消費者信頼感指数。
米二年国債入札。
独八月アイフォー景況感指数。
八月二十六日（水）日七月企業向けサービス価格指数。
米四〜六月期ジーディーピー（改定値）。
米七月耐久財受注。
米七月個人所得。
米七月個人消費支出（ピーシーイー）。
米五年国債入札。
決算、エヌビディア、他。
八月二十七日（木）ジャクソンホール会議（米国ワイオミング州、〜八月二十九日）。
米七年国債入札。
八月二十八日（金）日七月完全失業率。
日七月有効求人倍率。
日八月東京都区部消費者物価指数（シーピーアイ）。
日二年国債入札。
八月二十九日（土）。
八月三十日（日）。
**３．ブログではいえないお店**
**東京に来たら鮮魚を扱う大衆店が粉ものや中国産冷凍食品のお店になっていた件**
コロナ禍が明けてインバウンド観光客がたくさんやってくるようになったあとぐらいから、東京の飲食において、中途半端な価格帯のお店の鮮魚は地雷で、特に居酒屋なんかやべぇ、という話をなんどかしてきました。
それで、日本は乱獲によって年々シーフードが獲れなくなっているし、人手不足で店員が集まらないし、いっぽうで、東京の不動産だけはどんどん上がっていき、こうした状況で、単価五千円ぐらいのお店で美味しい刺し盛りとか提供できるわけがなく、それでも提供しているところは、もう廃棄寸前とか、他で値段がつかないやべぇもんが出てくるぞ、と警鐘を鳴らしてきたわけです。
もちろん、相続した店でやっているから家賃がゼロとか、お客様の笑顔を見るのが生きがいなんで原価率七十パーセントとかでやっているお店とかに行けばいいんですが、そういうところは予約困難店か、行列ができているのがふつうです。
しかし、僕はただ批判するだけじゃなくて、解決策も提示してきました。
東京での予算の限られた会食はイタリアンか中華でやれとか、居酒屋なら鮮魚はメニューになく、焼き餃子とか唐揚げとか（中国の工場で作った冷凍食品です）がメインのお店とかがいいんだ、と。
『週刊金融日記 第六百六十一号 安い外食が総じて悲惨になってきた東京でサバイブする食事方』。
『週刊金融日記 第七百十三号 高給取り以外が東京に住むのはもはや罰なのかもしれない、何度ハズレても微妙な客単価の居酒屋ガチャがやめられない理由と愛媛の美味い鯛めし』。
そして、久々に東京をプラプラ歩いていたら、僕の提言が、ちゃんと実施されてきているということを確認したわけです。
良い方向に進んでいるな、と。
僕はいま品川駅周辺のまあまあのレストランリストを作っているのですが、ジャックポットというお店は、ちょっと良いファミレス的イタリアンで、ピザとかとても美味しいし、ラムチョップも美味しいし、そして、生牡蠣もリーズナブルで美味しいのでオススメしようと思っていました。
ひとり五、六千円の会食には良いですし、ファミリーでも子どもはピザとかパスタとか食べて、おとなは生牡蠣とビールですわ。
品川駅の港南口の方にあるジャックポットはなかなか生牡蠣が良かったんですわ。
それで、ここのお店は、なんかリニューアルされたらしくて、見てみたら、ナポリピザが売りのレストランになっていました。
大きな窯がジャックポット時代からあったんで、美味しいピザとビールは、なかなか最高じゃないですか！
そして、メニューを見たら牡蠣がありません。
なんと粉ものとのピザとビールだけみたいなイタリアンになっていました。
これこそが、円安・インフレ・人手不足・シーフード不足の三重苦、四重苦にある東京の高級店以外の飲食店のあるべき姿です。
粉ものとのピザとか、どっかのセントラルキッチンとか、冷凍食品を活用したら、かなりコストを抑えられます。
やはり東京の大企業サラリーマンぐらいが客層の品川で、生牡蠣は無理ですね。
生牡蠣バンバン食べたら、一人一万円以上です。
そんなの流行るわけがありません。
『週刊金融日記 第七百三十九号 外食不毛の地の品川駅周辺のオススメのレストラン その一』。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十号 外食不毛の地の品川駅周辺のオススメのレストラン その二』。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十三号 外食不毛の地の品川駅周辺のオススメのレストラン その三』。
それで、街をプラプラしていたら、寿司セットが注文できる、まあまあの客単価五千円ぐらいの海鮮居酒屋があって、何回か行ったことあるんですが、そこもつぶれて「焼きうどん居酒屋」になっていました。
焼きうどんとか、こういうのがいいんですよ。
冷凍うどんとどっかの工場で効率よく作ったソースで、外国人のバイトが、ボタンひとつ押すだけで調理できる。
これなら、客単価四千円ぐらいで、衛生的で美味しい野菜も入った焼きうどんと、ビールがごくごくできます。
あと、他にも、微妙な価格帯の海鮮系のお店がつぶれていましたわ！
東京の飲食店もようやくまともになってきたな、と。
僕が提唱する、これからの東京の「あるべき居酒屋」の姿はこうです。
中国のハイテク工場で徹底した品質管理のもと大量生産された、美味しくて衛生的な餃子や小籠包、すでに完璧に味付けされた中華料理や野菜を、冷凍用コンテナでどんどん輸入します。
そして、店舗では、日本語がまだあまり上手じゃない外国人スタッフが、ボタンひとつのハイテク調理器で「チーン」と温めたり揚げたりして、最良の状態で提供します。
それをアテにして、僕たちは工業的に品質がしっかり管理された大量生産の美味しいビールをゴクゴクと飲むわけです。
この完全にシステム化されたオペレーションなら、人件費も食材のロスも極限まで削れますから、東京の不動産高騰下でも客単価四千円ぐらいの「居酒屋」が十分に成り立ちます。
そして、日本が世界に誇る美味しいトップクラスのシーフードは、数に限りがあります から、銀座や港区の客単価五万円を超えるようなお店で一部の富裕層が消費する以外は、どんどん輸出して外貨を稼げばいいんです。
韓国や台湾の半導体技術者たちが現地で舌鼓を打ったり、香港やシンガポール、北京や上海の高級レストランで出していけばいい。
限られた貴重な水産資源は、高く買ってくれるグローバル市場に回すのが経済の基本です。
もはや、普通のサラリーマンがふらっと入った居酒屋で、安くて美味い刺し盛りや手のかかる和食を食べられる時代は終わりました。
これからの流れは、東京の人々の胃袋を中国のハイテク食品工場が効率よく、そして、衛生的に満たしていくことですね。
この方面に大きなビジネスチャンスがあると僕は思っていますし、これこそが、インフレと人手不足の日本が目指すべき未来でしょう。
**４．ふじさわかずきの身もフタもない人生相談**
**キオクシアよりもエイチビーエムトップのエスケーハイニクスのほうがよいのでは**
キオクシアもエスケーハイニクスも、ピーイーアールや利益の伸び方は変わりません。
であれば、競合が生まれやすいナンドフラッシュのキオクシアよりも、競合が生まれにくくデータセンター用のエイチビーエムでトップを走るエスケーハイニクスの方がよいのではないでしょうか？
また、両者の業績見通しについてなぜ中間ではなく最悪を想定したような株価になっているかというと、負のオペレーティングレバレッジがあるからです。
最悪を想定したとき、設備投資が重すぎて一気に赤字に転落します。
その可能性を考慮すると、予想PER5倍前後も妥当ではないでしょうか。
ーふじさわかずきの回答
市場はPER5倍ぐらいをつけているのだから、市場はメモリ企業の利益が長続きしない、そのうち莫大な設備投資がペイしなくなる、と見ているというのは、まさに自明です。
あと、市場が最悪を想定しているかどうかは分かりませんが、仮に最悪を想定しているなら、最悪が起こった時に株価は横ばいで、最悪以外なら上がるわけで、期待値で見れば、こんな美味しい局面はそうそうない、ということになります。
我々のようなアクティブ投資家は、市場が間違っていると信じて賭けているわけで、市場だけが常に正しいと思えば、世界株インデックスファンドを買うことが論理的な帰結になります。
さて、SKハイニクスですが、いまの利益の絶対額、これからの利益の伸び、メモリ業界における技術優位性、そして、PER比などの指標による株価の割安さなどで考えれば、多くの人が、メモリ半導体株の中でも、一番だという評判ですよ。
あとは、地政学的に、アメリカ企業であるメリットを考えてMicronですね。
それで、Micronは、株価もメモリ半導体株の中ではだいぶマシです、相対的に高いですね。
僕も、SKハイニクスは前から推しているんで、実際に、KOSPIにぶっ込んでいます。
KOSPIは、だいたいSKハイニクスが3割で、サムスン電子が3割で、この2社で6割の指数なんですわ、笑。
だいぶ暴落してからKOSPI買って、もっと下がったところで、ちょうど日米協調介入だったんで、香港の法人口座で余っている円を売って、さらにKOSPIにぶっ込みましたわ。
いろいろ日本と似ている韓国ですが、老人の社会福祉は日本よりはるかに薄く、おばあちゃんもみんな飲食店とかで働いていて、韓国経済にはとても好感が持てます。
SK hynix 2026年Q2決算 過去最高利益と供給制約の現在地（Xサブスク）
サムスン電子2026年Q2決算 HBM4・長期供給契約・増産計画の全貌（Xサブスク）
ーオラクルに関してはどうお考えですか
お世話になります。
昨今の半導体関連のメルマガ楽しく拝見させていただいております。
エーアイや半導体関連株に強気のビューをお持ちかと存じますが、米株のオラクルに関してはどういうお考えをお持ちか伺いたく存じます。
オラクルチャート
私は長期的に見たら強い銘柄と思い、下落の度に買い増しをしております。
是非、オラクルに関しての藤沢所長のご見解をお聞かせいただければと存じます。
ーふじさわかずきの回答
僕は、エーアイのデータセンター屋さんがかなりボロい儲けだということを自分でしこしこ計算して知っていたので、エーアイツルハシ屋さんはもっとボロ儲けで、特にメモリ屋さんは、想像を絶するボロ儲けで、かつ不確実性が小さいんで、こっちが美味しすぎてハイパースケーラーまで手が出ない……、みんながネットで過剰投資で危ない危ないと言っていて、特にオラクルが一番最初に破綻する、みたいに盛り上がっていた時に、もっとオラクル暴落しねえかな、とずっと待っておりました。
みんなが恐怖で売った時に、拾いたかったんですよ。
しかし、残念ながらそこまで下がらんかったんですわ。
まあ、そんなんで売る人は、そもそも最初からオラクルなんか持ってないでしょうから、いまいち下がらんかったんですよね。
もう、エーアイのデータセンターが逼迫して、新しく建てようにも、いろいろ用地とか電力とかの問題でなかなか進まず、先に建てちゃった方が既得権益化してボロ儲け状態なんですよ。
土地でいえば、一等地に陣取ったわけですわ。
『週刊金融日記 第738号 エーアイ企業はトークン製造工場を建設してトークンを世界に売る簡単なビジネスです』
ー最近はエーアイと半導体の話が多いですが、中国株や中国の政治経済の話をもっと聞きたいです
初投稿です。
いつも楽しくメルマガを拝読しております。
中国株投資におけるカントリーリスクについて、中国の歴史や直近の有望株を交えたお話を、ハラハラしながら興味深く拝読しておりました。
しかしながらその後、話題が直近の半導体トピックへと移ってしまったため、カントリーリスク含めた中国株についてのお話の続きもぜひ伺いたいと、もどかしく感じております。
これからの展望も含め、是非に取り上げていただけますと幸いです。
ご検討のほどよろしくお願いします。
ーふじさわかずきの回答
もちろんです。
僕は、究極のバリュー、つまり割安に放置されている中国株は、コロナが明けて深セン行けるようになった2023年ぐらいに中国株投資を始めてからというもの、首尾一貫して強気です。
それで、良くも悪くも、大人気のエーアイ半導体株と違って、中国株、その中でも、国営っぽい高配当のバリュー中国株なんて、それらが適度に入っているハンセン株価指数とか、これは中国株ではありませんが高配当の香港のREITとか、放置して配当受け取っていればいいだけなんで、ついつい情報発信の頻度が下がってしまいますね。
そして、エーアイと先端半導体って、アメリカが統制する西側が、科学技術や製造業全般で、ほぼ唯一アドバンテージを持っている分野なんで、まあ、細かいことを見れば他にもいろいろありますが。
たとえば、大型旅客機用のジェットエンジンとか。
ここを見ていくということは、世界がこれかられきしてき規模でどうなっていくのか見ていくことになるんですよね。
『週刊金融日記 第694号 アメリカの制裁で花開きつつある中国のエーアイと半導体産業について解説します』
最近では、Xサブスクに、重要な中国企業の分析レポートをアップしましたが、これからは、Kimiなんかの中国のフロンティアエーアイも使いこなしながら、どんどん充実させていくつもりです。
美的集団（Midea）温暖化とエーアイ冷却で再評価よちがある割安高配当株
Lenovo 2026年、2027年Q1決算 PC首位からエーアイデータセンター企業へ
SMIC 2026年Q2決算 中国最大のファウンドリを読み解く
Tencent 2026年Q2決算 中国最大のスーパーアプリ企業をわかりやすく解説
ー結婚して週刊金融日記を卒業して早8年、セックスレスに耐えきれず帰って参りました
私、牧場主と申します。
2013年に読者になり、2018年に購読を止めておりましたところ、このたび恥ずかしながら帰って参りました。
ナチュラルボーン非モテのアラサーの頃に週刊金融日記に出会い、愚直に日々是精進、ぽつぽつと結果が出てきて、最高の女子を配偶者として迎えまして、それを機に週刊金融日記を卒業いたしました。
それからも変わらず他の女子に手を出したりして充実した毎日を送り、非モテウイルスはすっかり撲滅されたのかと思われました。
ところが、コロナ禍を境に活動量が落ち、なぜか同時期に配偶者ともセックスレスになりました。
いつの間にかセックスしたいという欲も湧いてこなくなりました。
相変わらずオナニーはしていましたが、あれほど盛んだった性欲はすっかり減退してしまったようでした。
歳のせいかな、まあ別にいいかと軽く考え、仕事も面白かったし趣味もあったので生活は充実していました。
それなのに、最近になって仕事への情熱が失せ、今まで楽しかったことがそうでもなくなってきました。
そして、反比例するように急にセックスがしたい、男としての自信を取り戻したいと思うようになりました。
気がつくと私は既婚者用マッチングアプリに手を出していました。
おっかなびっくり登録して、課金して、くっそ高い、マッチングするもトーク途中でスルスル相手が離脱していきます。
ようやく取れたアポも、お相手が逆パネマジ美女だったことに動揺し、非モテ発症のため無残な結果に終わりました。
一度は撲滅したかに思われていた非モテウイルスが本当は奥底に潜伏し、じわじわと増殖していたようなのです。
所長、私このままでは人生を終えられません。
今一度週刊金融日記読者として再出発し、不倫しまくりたいです。
こんな私に、喝を入れていただけませんでしょうか。
ーふじさわかずきの回答
牧場主さん、お帰りなさい。
いちど同志になった方でも、それぞれに理由があり、コミュニティを去った人も多くいます。
しかし、ひとつだけ確かなことは、週刊金融日記のドアはいつでもあなたのために開いている、ということです。
さて、僕も含めて、この数年は、週刊誌の読者の年齢層が時の経過とともに上がっていくように、良くも悪くも、昔のような金とか女とかより、もっと多様なことにテーマが移って行ったように思います。
僕はといえば、香港で、毎日、ユニクロの短パンにTシャツを着て、美味いもの食べたりして、ちんたらしておりましたわ。
そして、僕たちには、もう昔のような若さはないですし、デフレが終わったあとは、コストプッシュインフレがやってきて、多くの日本国民はさらに貧して、若者はだいぶ昔にすでに牙を抜かれ草食化していましたが、生き残っていた中年層も、LEON、つまりちょい不良オヤジを流行らせた小金持ちおっさんファッション誌も廃刊し、先日のジャンポケ斉藤氏の事件に代表されるように、日本社会のおかしな法改正や過剰コンプラによって、どんどん萎縮させられています。
『週刊金融日記 第744号 ジャンポケ斉藤氏への懲役7年求刑について』
これでは、いけないな、と僕も思っているところです。
ということで、いまではおっさんになった僕らが、また、戻ってきて、イケオジ、あるいは、痛いオジとして、世の中を面白くしていかないといけないな、と思っています。
テーマは、Rebornです。
ということで、僕はまずはファッション改善ということで、中国の深セン市でめちゃくちゃ服を買っているところですわ。
総額200万円ぐらいかかりそうなファッションを2、3万円で再現できます。
深セン・南油服装卸売市場の歩き方 2026年
そして、ファッションの前に、やはり溜まった体脂肪を落として、鍛える必要があります。
中高年のためのダイエット・筋トレ特集もしたいと思います。
乞うご期待です。
すみません、配信直前に気づいたのですが、LEONは、まだ廃刊してませんでした。
まだ、やってるんですね。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。